what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
yes i've gotten all of your comments all
of your tags all of your dms about this
new report
about when to expect the spider-man no
way home trailer
this report is coming from that show.com
and they are claiming that they have
heard
from multiple sources when the
spider-man no way home trailer
is going to be hitting theaters now
we've heard a lot of these reports over
the past
two to three weeks or so so i'm gonna go
ahead and tell you to take this with a
grain of salt
but since this is pretty much what
everybody is talking about right now i'm
gonna go ahead and break down their
report
and talk about if we really can't expect
to see spider-man
with black widow which is what they are
claiming and of course as always if i
ever hear
anything new about when to expect a
trailer i'll be sure to do a video so be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
so right away straight from the show.com
the article's title is
what you need to know about the
spider-man no way home trailer
this was written by nick santos and he
claims to have some pretty good
information
in the article he says that he has dug
around and he has confirmed this with
five
verifiable sources but he also says that
this
is not totally confirmed he does say
that he is confident
in the information but it is not
guaranteed he says however
i'm hearing that sony has sent out the
trailer to theaters under secure
lockdown
these theaters are ready to play the
trailer he then says from what my
sources are telling me
the no way home trailer will be playing
in front of black widow
no doubt to boost ticket sales and
revive fledging profit margins for
theater partners
now we'll talk more about this in just a
second but he goes on to say
as to when the trailer will make its way
online
that is currently unknown and that is a
rather interesting statement because
marvel
typically releases the trailers online
right when they release them during
a football game or the super bowl or a
basketball game
typically when they release the actual
trailers wherever they release them
online simultaneously so this would be a
very different move
for marvel however if the plan really is
to boost ticket sales for black widow
then it would make sense to only have it
play in the theaters because that is
what people would go to the theaters for
and they did hold out for that theater
release for black widow for a
very very long time the movie got pushed
back over a year
also black widow could get the attention
she deserves and could be on the big
screen like she deserves so the fact
that they
actually did hold off for this and
pushed for this means that they could
actually do some promotion to get people
to go and watch the film and marvel
knows if they put the spider-man no way
home trailer in front of black widow
everybody's gonna go flock to see it
they're smart and this would be a good
play now as far as the theaters actually
have in the trailer already and it being
under lockdown
this is what i've been talking about for
the past three weeks we've had reports
that theaters actually have the trailer
for a while now i've actually confirmed
with two personal sources that yes
the theaters do have the trailers
however this doesn't mean
that random people who work for the
movie theaters can watch the trailers
i've gotten a lot of comments and dms
from people stating oh i'm gonna go and
try to watch the trailer
my buddy's a manager or i know somebody
who works there that's not really how it
works though the trailers get sent to
the theaters but they're not accessible
they are protected by a password that
they are only given
when the trailer is actually ready to go
out and usually
that's the same day otherwise the
trailer would just be leaked so although
i definitely appreciate people trying to
go
watch the trailer it can't happen so i
can confirm this part of the report the
theaters have it and they are super
super protected now as far as the
trailer only playing in theaters and not
online that i'm not really sure about
the hashtag show seems pretty confident
about that and when i say take this
report with a grain of salt it has
nothing to do with them
they're pretty reputable it's just
spider-man reports in general nowadays
even if they're true can actually change
this makes sense it seems like something
marvel would do to try and boost the
sales of black widow and get people to
go and see it but at the same time it's
hard to imagine them not releasing it
online at the same time because they
know that people are going to go in and
just record the trailer on their phones
and leak it online and then everybody's
going to be talking about it and they
definitely know
that this is going to happen 100 which
is why i do think they would release it
online
at the same time so if this report does
end up being true black widow releases
on july 9th which means
that is when the spider-man no way home
trailer should drop now again take this
with a grain of salt even nick over at
the hashtag show says take it with a
grain of salt although he did say that
his website did crash due to everybody
coming to read the article so a lot of
people are talking about this right now
but fortunately we don't have to wait
much longer until july 9 to figure out
if this
is true or not if this doesn't happen
the trailer should be coming sometime in
july so at this point it's pretty much
just a waiting game but as always if i
hear anything concrete i'll be sure to
let everybody know
be sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you don't miss out
be sure to like the video and for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof